hey everyone it's a earth register nurse
sorry and calm and today we're going to
talk about the
renin-angiotensin-aldosterone system
also called the RAF's system and as
always after you get done watching this
youtube video you can access a free quiz
that will test you on this system so
let's get started
what does this system do and what is its
whole goal
well the rath system what it does is it
manages our blood pressure specifically
when that blood pressure drops so what
it's going to do is it's going to kick
into gear and it's going to increase the
blood pressure by getting a naturally
occurring substance on board in the body
called angiotensin 2 so that is the
whole goal of this system is to get
angiotensin ii activated and functioning
to help cause major vasoconstriction in
the body because when we constrict
vessels we increase blood pressure plus
angiotensin ii will help increase our
blood volume as well which will also
increase our pressure so let's go
through this system step by step until
we get to the end result angiotensin ii
now as we study this really let the
names of these substances help you out
because it's called the
renin-angiotensin-aldosterone system and
this is really the sequence of how these
substances are released so very first
thing happens our blood pressure drops
the body senses this and says oh no
we've got to deal with this
so the sympathetic nervous system is
stimulated and remember this is our
fighter flight system that helps save
our life so these nerves stimulate the
kidney specifically these cells called
juxta glomerular cells also called JG
cells and these cells are stimulated and
they will release a substance called
renin which is the first part of our
system so renin enters into circulation
now as it's flowing through circulation
it's going to do something it's going to
activate a substance in the liver called
Angie
Oh ten Synod jinn and once the substance
is activated because of this Wrentham it
is going to turn into angiotensin one
now remember we need to get to
angiotensin 2 so we have angiotensin so
we're in the second part of our whole
system name and since this angiotensin
is in the system and the vessels it is
going to really get this ace involved
because we need ace ace is going to help
us convert angiotensin 1 into
angiotensin 2 so ace stands for
angiotensin converting enzyme so it's
going to convert it for us and this ace
is found on the surface of the lung and
kidneys in the endothelium so it's going
to convert our angiotensin one to
angiotensin 2 now we're here we have
this awesome active vasoconstrictor
agent in our body that's going to help
us increase our blood pressure but how
does it do that we need to talk about
aldosterone right
okay so angiotensin 2 it's gonna act on
our smooth muscle vessels it's going to
constrict our vessels when we constrict
vessels that's going to increase
systemic vascular resistance and
increase our blood pressure to help you
visualize it or understand it think
about a water hose when we take that
water hose and we narrow it what happens
to the pressure of the water coming out
it's really gonna increase now another
way we can increase the water the
pressure coming out of that water hose
is if we increase the volume of the
amount of water coming out of the house
so we go to that faucet turn it up
that's going to increase the pressure
even more so that's what this
angiotensin ii is also going to do so
it's not only going to constrict our
vessels but it's going to help increase
blood volume now how does it do this
well it stimulates some other things
number one our kidneys are going to be
stimulated kidneys are going to start
conserving sodium and water at those
tubular sites within the nephron and
it's influenced by also another
substance which is produced by the
adrenal cortex
called aldosterone which is the last
part of the name of our system now
Dahlstrom what it is they're gonna do
it's going to also cause the kidneys to
keep sodium in water and it can also
lower our potassium level because the
kidneys will start to excrete it another
gland that's going to be stimulated
because of this angiotensin ii is the
pituitary gland and it's going to
release a substance called ADH
antidiuretic hormone also called
vasopressin and what this substance does
is it causes our kidneys to keep water
so we're keeping water even more water
we're gonna keep more water and sodium
over here and the kidneys are gonna do
that so what it's gonna do is it's gonna
increase the volume of blood which is
going to increase our blood pressure
even more so the end result of this
wrath system whenever it is working
correctly is we are going to increase
our blood pressure now in the previous
lecture we talked about ACE inhibitors
in these medications what do they do
they help lower the blood pressure and
right here
what ACE inhibitors do they prevent this
ace the angiotensin converting enzyme
from working and so you don't get the
conversion of angiotensin 1 to
angiotensin 2 so we have lower blood
pressure now let's illustrate this and
do a quick recap of this wrath system so
it will stick in your mind so we have
that drop in blood pressure sympathetic
nervous system is stimulated which will
send nerve impulses to those JG cells in
the kidneys which will cause them to
release renin into the circulation when
written as president of circulation it's
going to activate a substance in the
liver called angiotensinogen and this
will turn into angiotensin 1 now we want
angiotensin 1 to turn into that active
vaso constrictor so to do that you have
to have a switch is angiotensin
converting enzyme I remember this was
found on the endothelium in the lung and
the kidneys so ACE will turn angiotensin
1 in
angiotensin ii and angiotensin ii it's
gonna have some effects on the body one
thing it's going to do is it's going to
cause vasoconstriction so constrict
those vessels it's gonna cause the
kidneys to keep sodium and water which
is going to help increase blood volume
also you're gonna have aldosterone being
produced by that adrenal cortex and
that's found on top of the kidneys it's
going to help the kidneys also keep
sodium and water but remember potassium
will be excreted and then we also have
the pituitary gland who is going to
produce antidiuretic hormone ADH and
that's going to cause the body to keep
water all together they want to increase
blood volume we're constricting vessels
and this angiotensin ii is going to help
us increase blood pressure okay so that
wraps up this review over the
renin-angiotensin-aldosterone system
thank you so much for watching don't
forget to take the free quiz and to
subscribe to our channel for more videos